le groupe l'est républicain de la parole
merci monsieur le président alors ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
ministre le président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy
tir depuis lundi la sonnette d'alarmé
l'épidémie de lakovic 19 est incontrôlée
et la situation dans nos hôpitaux
devient très périlleuse certains
services de réanimation sont d'ores et
déjà saturé l'épidémie flambent et des
français meurent votre devoir monsieur
le ministre est non seulement de
protéger à tout prix les français
mais c'est aussi et avant tout
d'anticiper le conseil scientifique
avait prévu dès juillet qu'il y aurait
une deuxième vague
aujourd'hui cette vague déferle
incontrôlée et les français ont le
sentiment que rien n'a été anticipé
depuis la fin du confinement
les français notamment ont le sentiment
que rien n'a changé à l'hôpital par
rapport au printemps
il est vrai que l'organisation
hospitalière aurait mérité que soit
élaboré un plan d'anticipation pendant
l'été afin de pouvoir augmenter
rapidement le nombre de soignants et
permettre l'ouverture d'un plus grand
nombre de lits de réanimation
alors monsieur le ministre plutôt que de
dévaloriser certaines professions
paramédicales en donnant des
autorisations temporaires d'exercice à
des personnes qui n'ont pas d'expérience
pourquoi ne pas s'autoriser à surclasser
via un temps de formation et pour
quelques tâches limiter les aides
soignants et les infirmiers comme l'a
suggéré le professeur philippe juvin
chef du service des urgences de
l'hôpital georges pompidou à paris
on vous répondra par les communes et des
solidarités
pour le coup madame la sénatrice drexler
vous avez parfaitement raison il faut
anticiper et être capable de former
davantage de personnel soignant est
d'ailleurs dans votre question vous
n'avez pas suggérer comme j'ai pu
l'entendre ça et là que nous aurions pu
former davantage d'anesthésistes pendant
l'été puisque chacun sait qu'il faut
disant néanmoins madame la sénatrice
quand je dis vous avez raison c'est que
non seulement je considère que vous avez
raison mais je considère que c'est ce
que nous avons fait et nous c'est pas le
gouvernement et c'est pas vous les
sénateurs c'est l'ensemble c'est les
régions ce sont les hôpitaux ce sont les
facultés qui se sont organisés je vais
vous donner quelques exemples
d'abord nous avons supprimé le concours
d'entrée dans les études et soignante
dans notre pays nous l'avions fait avant
la crise sanitaire aucun regret de
l'avoir fait les régions augmenter le
nombre de places de formation plus de
1000 places cette année de formation
pour les infirmières plus de 1000
augmentation de place pour les aides
soignants alors ça prend du temps pour
former des aides-soignants et des
infirmières vous l'avez dit vous-même
dans votre question mais nous sommes
dans l'anticipation en prévoyant que
nous aurons peut-être besoin dans un an
ou deux de milliers de soignants plus
sur certains territoires oui madame la
sénatrice nous recrutons des faisant
fonction des aides soignants les agents
de soins qui ont des missions qui sont
moins qualifiés
c'est pas déshonorant je les fais je les
fais pendant près de trois ans quand
j'étais jeune étudiant et j'ai été aide
soignant jusque je suis monté jusqu'au
niveau d'être soignants en ehpad
j'ai effectué des missions à lorient
n'avait pas la qualification et je crois
avoir fait mon travail avec soin et
conviction et attention pour les
personnes dont je m'occupais par
ailleurs madame la sénatrice nous
voulons faire revenir à l'hôpital des
personnes qui ont quitté l'hôpital ou
revenir en ehpad
vous serez amené à voter la semaine
prochaine le plfss 8 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation pour les soignants
non-médicaux plus de 200 euros
d'augmentation nets par mois pour les
aides soignants ça c'est un outil
d'attractivité madame la sénatrice je
pense que vous en conviendrez avec moi
nous augmentons toutes les capacités de
formation de tous les instituts de
formation de france et nous mobilisons
partout nous pouvons deux exemples
rapidement en nouvelles aquitaine pôle
emploi reçoit actuellement en entretien
trois cents personnes qui sont inscrites
à pôle emploi qui sont aide soignante
pour les inciter à rester un peu
davantage dans la branche
professionnelle un autre exemple dans le
finistère un dispositif de recrutement
dead à domicile pour des personnes
licenciées du secteur de
l'agroalimentaire
été mis en place etc etc des initiatives
comme celle là elles nous permettent de
renforcer les rangs des soignants de
plusieurs milliers de plusieurs milliers
de blouses blanches dont nous avons
besoin et je voulais à travers votre
question il ma réponse les remercier
pour leur engagement